we went from a clean upbringing into a
world of dirty tricks in your mature
life yeah
but the key thing is that as you get
recruited into the CIA it never occurs
to you that if you're if you're as naive
as I was and I think most of the young
men that come into the CIA are it never
occurs to you that you're getting into a
world of dirty tricks you're the come on
that they have that the things they use
to sell is that you're finally getting
into the elite inner circles of the
United States government all your life
you've been going through the amateurs
and the prelims and the the prep schools
in effect and finally this is it this is
where the people are real pros the
frontline warriors saving the nation
from Communists the Phoenix program was
created by the CIA and its purpose was
to kill and terrorize and Vietnam was
forced to do business with police chief
who was a sadistic mutilator of
prisoners he liked to carve them up and
throw the remains in the river and he
was completely paid and popped up by the
CIA his whole career depended on one
controlling that operation so that the
CIA needed him and to the cie propping
him up and funding him and he did his
knife work in a CIA safe house I called
it the pink house I reported this to the
chief of station and he said well you
know it's a rough world and sometimes
you have to do business with people that
really aren't your first choice of kind
of people you want to associate with so
don't make a way and so I went back you
know what I do resign my post yeah you
know that's obviously that's your last
vote though you resign and you're out
and I wasn't ready to give up my career
yet I terminated the safe house I told
case officers that I don't want to hear
about it if this guy has a compulsion to
do this sort of thing anymore I don't
want to hear about it yeah I know about
recruiting
future candidates for officers and
agents hmm have any of you all been
approached here as a recruiters come
through here and talk you know somebody
in this room might be sweating right now
because he's been told you know if they
ask you to say anything to keep my eyes
out in their classes for Victor students
they might be interested in that sort of
work but I wonder how were you
approached here at the University we
approached sometime later in your career
at the University of CI recruiter came
through I went and talked to them he did
not write my name down and in 64 early
64 I got a letter in the mail saying
what I mind if the CIA did a security
check and I wrote back saying I was
Restless and I wrote back saying I'd be
delighted if it was for possible
employment with my background there were
fields where I would be unique
from the Congo I went to the University
of Texas and enrolled in the ROTC
program
I graduated in 1959 and took a
commission in the Marine Corps I didn't
see my future as a career officer so
when my term was up I accepted an offer
as a junior executive at the gates
Rubber Company and went with my family
to Colorado we were very young and
idealistic with three children when the
CIA first approached us we were in the
Marine Corps for three years and did not
want to go the military route although
there was a very promising career there
when you think about his job being
career or national security I think that
at the time the emphasis was career I
think that most of what he did was for
the next fitness report so speak I think
that people generate activity that is
unnecessary overseas in order to have
some activity on their fitness report
and they really don't get promoted
within the CIA unless they have so many
recruitments let's say in a tour of duty
are so many operations or ops as they
call them the way the CIA works you're
promoted on the basis of your fitness
report which you get every few months or
at the end of every assignment at least
once a year usually morale and this
evaluates your performance both with a
letter grade and also a written
narrative that and the assignment you
get will will develop your career I
think why don't you just go in there and
tell them that this has been morale and
this is something you can't do and he
said well they don't want you're not
gonna get anywhere in your career if you
say no to assignments and by that time
though he was hooked by the CIA and the
assignments were sexy assignments and
interesting assignments and one post we
put seven bugs in a foreign embassy it
was a quite dramatic and very exciting
and we had officers and support officers
and technicians flying all over Africa
on this thing and we got him in of the 7
bugs that we installed clean we never
got caught
five of them never came up on the air
they were totally defective the sixth
one would transmit but you switch the
activator to shut off the thing no one
was speaking was defective so it burned
out its batteries in the course of about
six weeks time and went off the air and
one of them functioned properly and that
one although it was in an ambassador's
office of a country that was very much a
target of intelligence activities that
one never produced a single dissemble
report I felt like I was really making
time professionally I was a very young
officer when I met my first president we
had a mutual interest there were things
I could do for him and there were things
he could do for us at least in terms of
making me feel secure in his country if
I was meeting him and he appreciated
what I was doing for him it wasn't
likely that he was gonna throw me out if
I made a mistake or got caught and it
was pretty heady stuff for a very young
officer and it meant that I was getting
recognition back at headquarters
obviously you know there's young
Stockwell who's meeting President X and
we better keep our own stock well he
looks good
my function at home when agents would
come to the home would be to turn on the
record player and be sure that the
curtains were closed and that there was
enough security in my own home that the
person wouldn't you know be compromised
by having come to our home I didn't
really at that time I didn't realize
that we would be putting these people in
danger and that some would be put in
jail and that some would be dead a lot
of other things happen in the world
that's sort of like somebody pushing a
rock off the cliff and the rock hits
somebody and and then you know they step
back and say I didn't kill him now the
rock killed him and this is sort of what
happened in Ghana the the agency to my
knowledge did not write a paper saying
let's overthrowing cream on the chief of
station there was a very aggressive man
and he became aware of the fact that
there was the possibility of a coup
developing and he knew the players
people who in the army who are unhappy
and he began to report and to ask for
encouragement to encourage these men and
as I understand it he was not given a
formal permission to attempt overthrow
Nkrumah but he was given permission to
monitor the developments of any coup and
this gave him an excuse to to meet these
officers often daily several times a day
and to give them money and in effect to
give them encouragement the soft file is
a file that doesn't have an official
name on it or krypton him on it and is
not registered into the agency's IBM
system the system of 201 numbers so that
it can't be traced if if you come to the
agency demanding to see your file and if
they have a soft file on you instead of
a 201 you will never get it they may
have a manila folder in there with with
reams of documents about you and you
will never get access to it there were
times when I said well let's just get
out of the CIA you know Bob really
you're making a decision which is it's
it's getting to the point where it's
going to be the CIA or it's going to be
our marriage and he chosen CIA